The Cognotic desktop application is extensible. You can install a
plug-in by clicking Plugins from the main page. Clicking
upload plugin, choose file. Selecting the plug-in jar
You may want to check auto load and then upload
plugin. Upon starting this plug-in
asks you to accept license agreement, which is OK. And
this Plug-in also requires You to be on
Patreon. And verify your subscription status
This plug-in is for. Supporters of my
Patreon. Once you click out. Allow
on that we can close that. And then Refresh
the homepage and you see some extra options that we
can go over and as you can see plugin installation
is simple and adds working applications.